metteur en scène en résidence à saint
quentin en yvelines il crée un spectacle
par an et s'intéresse cette fois à la
légende de la ville d'ys symbole d'une
christianisation forcée mise en oeuvre
par une rom soucieuse de perdurer à
travers la religion catholique ça vous
intrigue godefroy ségal nous en dit plus
dans le kiosque sur ce spectacle
intitulé plus que le tumulte des eaux
profondes
cette légende parle effectivement de la
christianisation de l'occident dans le
sens où finalement pourquoi c'est un des
premiers textes cette légende finalement
aura là au départ donc sans doute chanté
dans bel est ce qu'on appelait des
délais à l'époque et relayé comme ça par
les les les bardes et les futurs poète
aimait de ces siècles qui ont été
totalement sacrifié par la mémoire c'est
à dire que des hommes ont sans doute
délibérément décidé de ne laisser aucune
trace sur la période en gros qui va du
3ème 4ème siècle après jésus-christ
jusqu'au 7e 6e 7e 8e siècle cette ville
païenne qui aurait été totalement
submergée par les flots était une façon
effective de raconter la fin du
paganisme et du coup dans la douleur les
débuts de la christianisation maintenant
c'est vrai que la plupart des historiens
sont assez d'accord pour dire qu'elle
s'est fait en sang dans la douleur
[Musique]
le roi gradlon qui aurait vécu au 4e
siècle qui était effectivement un celte
mais faisant partie des armées romaines
en tant que tribun romain et qui aurait
épousé une des dernières rennes païenne
du nord avec laquelle il aurait eu une
fille à s elle va demander à son père de
pouvoir vivre un petit peu à l'écart
c'est à dire de lui bâtir une ville qui
seraient entre la mer et les ter nous
allons à rendre
j'ai pas
la première fois
je crains un prix je crains de vivre
demain à partir ma fille
forte wars
c'est un risque de se tendre à
rome ne va pas supporter de voir cette
ville énorme païenne donc ils ont envoyé
un émissaire plus malins qu'on a appelé
comme ça durant les différentes périodes
le rouge le rouge ça voulait dire en
bretagne quand vous voyez un village qui
s'appelle la motte-rouge quoi que ce
soit c'était des camps romains les
rouges étaient les romains c'était dû à
leur cap effectivement ils vont envoyer
un homme plus malins qui va séduire as
il va effectivement par devoir vis-à-vis
des roms ouvrir les portes de la ville
la ville va être submergé en une nuit
cité a été frappé par les eaux
ce fut temps là des 383 de notre ère
his du super g
one man long
soudain murmure de la très sainte etc
offrit sa fille au flou
la donna la mort
la regarde à mourir
et réchappe un naufrage
grâce à l'alliance pour laquelle il
avait on année
alors effectivement l'engloutissement
d'une ville sur scène posait beaucoup de
problèmes et finalement mettre de l'eau
sur scène ça donne pas l'océan c'est à
dire que en y pensant on se fait plaisir
techniquement c'est compliqué pour les
salles mais bon et en même temps ça
remplace pas moi ce qu'est ce qui
m'intéresse dans cette histoire c'est la
puissance de l'océan c'est pour ça qu'un
jour j'ai pensé effectivement à a
représenté
l'océan et les éléments de la nature
plutôt par un choeur par une chorale
effectivement qui accompagnent les
comédiens tout le monde du spectacle sur
une composition originale de laurent
petit gant
[Musique]
oh
vous
le dispositif scénique en main est quand
même assez simple j'espère qu'il sera
relativement
beau mais simple de simples planches
quoi où les comédiens vont oeuvrer comme
ça sans jamais sortir de scène
est maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction par la non par la mort de son
travail
pensez depuis plusieurs années le centre
de ressources et d'interprétation de
port royal voit enfin le jour un lieu
paisible au coeur du site de port royal
des champs comme une invitation au livre
d'abord en s'adressant aux fréquentes en
du musée aux personnes qui viennent
visiter le lieu c'est à part l'objectif
on vient accompagner répondre à des
intérêts de lecture
en début ou en fin de visite sur sap
être sûr champaigne ça peut être sûr
peut-être la prochaine exposition restos
qui se prépare dans le salon de lecture
trois mille volumes sont consultables
sur place parmi les thématiques abordées
le jansénisme et plus largement
l'histoire de france et le xviie siècle
quant à blaise pascal et jean racine
figure référente de port royal leur
ouvrage occupe une place privilégiée
si le centre de ressources se tournent
principalement vers les chercheurs il
compte beaucoup sur les étudiants de
l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines le son de ressources on ya
accès avec le hall d'entrée parc et on
va on a créé une carte de lecteur un
listes d'électeurs qui permet d'avoir un
accès libre ensuite facilité forcément à
partir d'une régularité de fréquentation
à chaque saison des visites thématiques
sont proposées au public pour échanger
sur l'histoire de port-royal prochain
rendez vous hivernal samedi 12 janvier
autour des artisans de l'histoire
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
de bien négocier le passage à l'année
2013 le 13 janvier la chorale saint
quentin gospel se produire à la ferme de
bel ébat le 19 janvier l'excellent
charles gonzales deviendra camille
claudel thérèse d'avila et sarah kane à
la maison de la poésie de saint quentin
en yvelines tandis que max boublil se
produira à la même date en sketches et
en chansons à la merise attrape des
dates que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet aux adresses qui s'affiché
cette semaine sur le
www.kia.ca qui point fr vous pouvez
gagner des places pour le mur de
l'equilibre le spectacle du cirque akya
équilibristes pascal rousseau présentait
à la ferme du mousseau alors bonne
chance à tous et bonne année
c